>> Greg: WELCOME BACK.
AS ELON'S OFFER FINALLY CLEARS,
TWITTER EMPLOYEES DROWN IN THEIR
TEARS.
MUSK'S TWITTER TAKEOVER'S
EXPECTED TO BE OFFICIAL TOMORROW
BUT THE BILLIONAIRE FREE SPEECH
AD VOW INDICATE IS ALREADY
MAKING HIMSELF AT HOME.
A LOT OF WORKERS MAY BE AXED AND
EVEN MORE MAY BECOME PREGNANT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: HE HAS LIKE TEN KIDS OR
SOMETHING.
YESTERDAY HE TWEETED VIDEO OF
HIMSELF STROLLING INTO THE LOBBY
LITERALLY CARRYING A SINK.
HE CAPTIONED IT, ENTERING
TWITTER HQ, LET THAT SINK IN.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN FUNNY IF IT
WAS A TOILET AND CAPTIONED IT
WITH LET'S POTTY.
HUH?
YEAH.
DON'T CLAP.
I KNOW YOU WANTED TO.
IT WASN'T LONG BEFORE LIBERALS
STARTED MELTING DOWN FASTER THAN
GRETA THUNBERG AT A MONSTER
TRUCK RALLY.
SAYING IT'S SO CRUEL AND HE'S A
PIECE OF TRASH.
AND THEY SAID IT ON TWITTER SO
THEY SHOULD THANK HIM FOR THE
PRE SPEECH THE INGREATS.
MUSK FOLLOWED UP SAYING IT'S
IMPORTANT TO THE FUTURE
CIVILIZATION TO HAVE A COMMON
TOWN SQUARED.
MEANWHILE TWITTER'S BRATS ARE
PROVING IT'S AS ESSENTIAL AS
JAMES CORDEN'S RUNNING SHOES.
TOSSED AN OPEN LETTER ABOUT
ELON'S PLAN TO FIRE 75% OF THEM
QUOTE A THREAT OF THIS MAGNITUDE
ITS RECKLESS UNDERMINES OUR
USERS AND CUSTOMER'S TRUST IN
OUR PLATFORM AND IS THE
TRANSPARENT ACT OF WORKER
INTIMIDATION.
SOMEONE SHOULD FLAG THAT FOR
MISINFORMATION.
SO LIKE DEATH ROW INMATES
REQUESTING CUSHIONS FOR THE
ELECTRIC CHAIR THE PEOPLE ABOUT
TO BE FIRED WROTE UP A LIST OF
DEMANDS.
THEY WANT RESPECT, SAFETY,
PROTECTION, DIGNITY.
HELL, IF THEY WANT ALL THAT THEY
SHOULD JUST COME WORK FOR ME.
>> HEY, GUYS, GREAT WORK ON THE
SCRIPTS TODAY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: JIMMY, IT'S SO ADORABLE
THAT THEY WROTE UP A LIST OF
DEMANDS.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE THE CHRISTMAS
LIST BY A FIVE YEAR OLD AND
DADDY'S LIKE YOU'RE NOT GETTING
ANY OF THIS.
>> Jimmy: IT'S LIKE ME BEING
BEYONCE I'LL ONLY DATE YOU ON
THESE TERMS.
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> Jimmy: THANKS FOR COMING,
DRIVE SAFE.
MY FAVORITE PART OF THIS WHOLE
SOCIETAL MELTDOWN OF ELON MUSK
BUYING TWITTER IS ALL THE
ANGRIEST PEOPLE DRIVE A TESLA.
HAVE YOU EVER THOUGHT ABOUT THAT
FOR A SECOND.
IT'S LIKE THIS GUY WAS YOUR
PATRON SAINT, YOU KNOW WHAT I
MEAN?
WE'RE ACTUALLY BANNING GAS CARS
AND THE BIGGEST ELECTRIC VEHICLE
MANUFACTURER IN THE WORLD IS NOW
CONSIDERED HITLER.
BUT WHAT I THINK THE LEFT IS
GETTING WRONG IS THEY SHOULD
WANT FREE SPEECH ON TWITTER
BECAUSE IT DIVERTS OUR ATTENTION
AWAY FROM HOW CRAZY THEIR
POLICIES HAVE GOTTEN.
WHEN TRUMP WAS AROUND CALLING
ROSIE O'DONNELL A LAND WHALE
EVERY TUESDAY AND THURSDAY THE
LEFTWARD LUNCH HAD ALREADY
BEGUN.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
PAYING ATTENTION TO IT'S NOT
NEW.
THEY WERE SAYING MEN COULD GET
PREGNANT THREE YEARS AGO WE ARE
HE JUST PAYING ATTENTION TO IT
NOW.
>> Greg: I THINK THE MEDIA
OPERATES UNDER THE ASSUMPTION
THAT EVERYONE AT TWITTER LEAVING
ARE ALL CODERS.
NO, THEY'RE MARKETING DRONES CAT
LADIES AND THE TYPICAL --
>> Kat: HEY.
>> Greg: SORRY.
ANYWAY YOU KNOW WHERE I'M GOING.
>> Wilfred: I'M A CAT GENTLEMAN
MYSELF.
BUT I THINK IF YOU'VE EVER
WATCHED ONE OF THOSE VIDEOS LIKE
MY FIRST DAY AT WORK AT TWITTER
IT'S STRAIGHT UP SIPPING LATTE
IN THE MORNING AND WINE IN THE
AFTERNOON AND PLAYING BAGS.
SO THE BACKGROUND IS COMPLETELY
SERIOUS.
ELON MUSK SAID WHEN HE COMES
INTO TWITTER HE'S GOING TO FIRE
ABOUT 75 TO 80% OF TWITTER STAFF
AS USELESS AND THAT REALLY IS
THE KIND OF OPPRESSION ISSUE AT
TWITTER.
THAT WHOLE ECOSYSTEM OF PEOPLE
PARTYING AND HOOKING UP AND
COMPLAINING ONLINE IS SUPPORTED
BY LIKE 400 PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY
KNOW HOW TO CODE.
PEOPLE LIKE FROM CAL POLY,
THAT'S WHO'S ACTUALLY DOING THE
WORK THERE.
>> Greg: SO TRUE AND HE KNOWS
THAT BECAUSE HE LOOKED UNDER THE
HOOD KAT.
HE SAW HOW IT WORKS.
HE BASICALLY TOOK THE MAKEUP OFF
MRS. DOUBTFIRE
>> Kat: I DIDN'T SEE THAT ONE I
JUST THOUGHT IT WAS CLEVER.
SO MUCH SO I USED IT TWICE
TODAY.
>> Tyrus: GERALDO DIDN'T GET IT
THEN
>> Kat: I LOVED THEIR LITTLE
LETTER BUT MY FAVORITE PART WAS
THEY SAID WE CALL ON TWITTER
MANAGEMENT AND ELON MUSK TOING
SEES THESE NEGLIGENT LAYOFF
TLETHS.
LIKE, SURE, THAT WILL WORK.
BUT I KNOW WHY THEY PROBABLY
THINK IT WILL, BECAUSE IT DID
WORK EVERY TIME THEY DID THIS
WHEN THEY WANTED A SPEAKER TO
NOT COME TO CAMPUS WHEN THEY
WERE IN COLLEGE.
I WORKED.
>> Greg: RIGHT.
SO THAT'S THE LESSON THEY
LEARNED IN SCHOOL
>> Kat: YEAH.
THEY'RE LIKE I KNOW WHAT TO DO
HE'S NOT GOING TO COME HERE.
>> Greg: BUT IT TRANSLATED INTO
ACTUAL CORPORATE WORLD UNTIL YOU
GOT A REAL BOSS.
THESE PEOPLE DO EXIST TYRUS.
WHERE ARE THEY GOING TO GO?
ARE YOU GOING TO HOUSE SOME OF
THESE PEOPLE?
>> Tyrus: SURE.
>> Greg: HIRE AN ASSISTANT.
>> Tyrus: YEAH.
I'LL ASSIST THEM.
SPEAKING OF ASSISTS, MR. MUSK IF
YOU NEED CLEANING OUT DESKS AND
WALKING PEOPLE OUT, I AM 1,000%
AVAILABLE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Tyrus: BECAUSE, AS YOU KNOW
WITH HOW I RAISE MY CHILDREN,
NOT JUST THE SEA TURTLE
MOVEMENT, I ALSO BELIEVE IN
REAL-LIFE CONSEQUENCES AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THE WOKE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO STEER THEIR
LITTLE SHIP AWAY FROM EVERYBODY
AND NEVER BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
BEHAVIORS OR RUINING SOMEONE'S
LIFE ET CETERA.
NOW HERE'S THE DEAL,
CORPORATION, YOUR COMPANY GOT
BOUGHT.
IN EVERY OTHER WORLD THERE'S
LAYOFFS.
YOU GET LET GO.
THEY BRING THE THEIR GUYS.
SO WELCOME TO THE REAL WORLD.
SO YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO DO
LATTES AND WINE AT MOM AND DAD'S
HOUSE.
YOUR LITTLE NOTE, WE HE
APPRECIATES THE EFFORT YOUR
ASSES ARE GONE AND THEY SHOULD
BE GONE AND THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS.
IF A NEW TEAM CAME IN HERE
TOMORROW, LET'S SAY COBURN AND
KIMMEL GOT TOGETHER AND IN SOME
WEIRD POKER GAME THEY GOT THE
GUTFELD SHOW, DO YOU THINK IT
WOULD BE THE GUTFELD SHOW
ANYMORE?
NO.
AND ALTHOUGH WALKING YOU OUT,
ALTHOUGH PAINFUL, I'M KEEPING MY
JOB.
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: WHY ARE YOU APPLAUDING
THAT?
I COULD HAVE ALL OF YOU TOSSED
OUT INTO THE STREETS AND WILL
NEVER AIR THIS SHOW.
WILL NEVER AIR IT.
>> Wilfred: FIRST THEY'RE
YELLING ABOUT BUSES
>> Kat: WE WOULD HAVE TO AIR I